strain my day junkie block my night all
day yeah yeah if your [ __ ] Mighty Mouse
is more technical than yeah you know
yeah anybody really know about him TJ
ain't happening
yeah PJ feeling like now I got to pay me
like it's and you know I love TJ I know
you probably listen I for DJ it doesn't
make sense for Mighty Mouse you're my
team s it does not make lies why TJ I
didn't have the belt it's not a super
fight he would super fights equals super
money they want it's not a needle mover
unfortunately as if I would love to see
the fights a ridiculous fight so what is
his Mighty Mouse said no to it without
rate it was like ain't happening wow the
UFC wants to happen he's like not good
it ain't happening red boards the next
contender isn't that interesting that he
can make those calls too
I mean it's one of those weird things
it's like in boxing you know you have
mandatory challengers and then you know
then you try to make super fights in the
UFC it's like two like hey we've got a
fight for you and he's like I'm the
champ well but it's rare right like if
you only have one title defense you
better get the [ __ ] played play with us
you know I'm saying it's a [ __ ]
because right now like you have to have
order like I'm all about super fights we
have to have order otherwise you know
think about if TJ went down and what
happened to Cody Garbett fight lemons
with DJ's you know I'm saying but
there's Conor McGregor kind of
phenomenon it was trying to do it yeah
well I think TJ just went through a huge
camp and he wants a fight you know I
mean he's done through this giant camp
getting ready for Cody I did it and you
know Cody they were trying to pressure
him to fight he they even sent him down
I don't know why doesn't drought in
Germany cause it kind of infirmity to
get the same [ __ ] you can get in Santa
Monica weird is that well Dana doesn't
believe that it's the same and I don't
understand that so what what is wrong
with Cody he's got a black issue yeah
he's got a back issue what is we know
he's got something with his disc and he
needs time off he needs spinal
decompression and he's got the Regina
Kane he went and got a full treatment
they say they'll be ready by September
October
yeah may not a wait maybe but you have
to absolutely make sure it heals first I
sent him a bunch of information I sent
him the reverse hyper machine
send them some stuff on spinal
decompression and he's also talking that
dr. Davidson who they're starting to do
some struggling and yeah he's he's
brilliant they're starting to do some
stuff now in the UFC where they're the
the stem-cell doctors are now going to
inject stem cells into discs and they're
going to regenerate disk tissue that's
cool
it's amazing this is a favorite part no
yes oh yeah yeah leaves Cleveland be
they've got [ __ ] they've got studies
that they've done enough of them now
that they have some real good evidence
that it does regenerate the same way it
regenerates cartilage and ligaments and
but there's a lot of times with the
entries where you know sometimes that's
not going to be enough you're right it
depends on the injury a lot of times
those stem cells so it's just sometimes
your [ __ ] yeah all right a lot of that
is that there hasn't been that much
conclusive evidence to for example that
it grows yeah when you shoot it into
something I've coated with negative it
doesn't necessarily regenerate sometimes
you know or a lot well it's it's very
difficult to say why it works on some
people why it doesn't work on other
people but I say zlotys yeah case by
case but I think one factor is whether
or not you come back too quick and
that's what what Cody did Cody got the
stem cells and started working out like
four days later but you can't do that
that's not smart you can't do that I
mean you know a cliff he's got a fight
he's got a big title fight and you
actually took two weeks off or something
like that but you need like months you
need a lot of time you need to have your
body heal it's a very difficult area to
heal and a lot of people don't do it
correctly and then they wind up getting
some serious atrophy where the nerves
get pinched the swelling and all the
inflammation and Cody needs to take it
slow come back in in that TJ fly to be
there but you can't rush that fight
[Applause]
[Music]